[Music]
in tonight's special report focused on
the midterms bret bear interviews the
newest republican candidate for the
pennsylvania senate seat tv's dr oz
brett
thanks mike in tonight's special report
spotlight on the midterms the
pennsylvania senate race received some
star power this week dr mehmet oz of the
dr oz tv show is now running as a
republican candidate for senate the
current senator republican pat toomey
will not run for re-election one gop
candidate sean parnell who was endorsed
by former president trump has already
dropped out after a bitter custody
battle with his ex-wife
but there are still almost a dozen other
candidates in the republican side who
have announced and there are already a
dozen democrats in the running tonight
we have dr mehmet oz with us to explain
why he's entering the race dr oz thanks
for being here
glad to be with you brett so a lot of
people look at this and say why i mean
you've got a successful tv show you're
you've had a tremendous run
on television and around the world why
do this now
brett my parents were immigrants to this
country were afforded unbelievable
opportunities i owe a debt i've always
felt it
and america is in crisis now so i think
it's an ideal time for me to repay that
debt by serving this country and running
as a senator from the state of
pennsylvania i see our values under
attack many of the issues you talk about
frequently keep me up at night i believe
americans deserve better and there's
solutions out there that are evident
that we're not taken advantage of but we
are spending too much time
taking people who've got good ideas and
shaming them and silencing them and
bullying them and canceling them and
i'll tell you something in medicine if
we cannot say what we see with our own
eyes people die
and these choices i think should be the
people watching the show right now for
me specifically the people in
pennsylvania i have fought to empower
folks my whole career i've taken on big
pharma on the show i've taken on big
tech agrochemical companies i've got the
scars to prove it and i can't be bought
and this is the time if i'm ever going
to do it to jump out of the comfort and
the safety of a tv show or frankly even
in the operating room i don't get
attacked usually by people and starts
talking about things that really can
make our country succeed because i'm so
optimistic you know you have a primary
to go through on the republican side i
put up the candidates already out but
there's one that has not declared yet
but might david mccormick is being
recruited former treasury under
secretary for international affairs
combat veteran business executive
do you expect he's going to get in and
why are you better positioned if he does
i'm not sure what's going to happen with
mr mccormick i haven't spoken to him but
i know that i have 94 name recognition
in pennsylvania it's very hard to get
there takes years and years of hard work
and and lots of effort talking to people
in their own living rooms i know that i
fare well with republican audiences who
know that i share their values i don't
speak generally on the show of overtly
political issues but during covet i got
political because unfortunately if you
mix medicine politics you get politics
so i had to get engaged to try to help
our country deal with the fact that we
were myopically focused on some issues
and blind to others and we're taking
chances by using our children as shields
and addressing other changes that happen
to our society under the cover of covet
i want to talk to you about covet and
about the biden administration policy
but you mentioned pennsylvania
specifically and and you're running here
already there are some people that are
suggesting that you know you're moving
in basically to run for the senate seat
here is uh stephen colbert on this issue
he may have fake pennsylvania claims
because he's running there despite
living in new jersey for years and
there's a big difference between
pennsylvania and new jersey
something to do with hoagies i don't
know what it is but they will murder you
over it
now he's joking about the hoagies but
what about that the carpet bagging
charge
you know i grew up just south of here
i'm in philadelphia uh just across the
state border i went to medical school at
penn here in philadelphia i went to
wharton business school met my wife the
best decision of my life was marrying
her here in philadelphia at the church
just down the road from where i am now i
had my first two kids here i mean i
spent a lot of time in pennsylvania i
did move to new jersey because
television is done in new york city and
it was convenient but we came back here
all the time and we moved back last year
both to spend time with their parents
but also because this is home and we
feel very comfortable here you know you
mentioned covid and the policies
considering this travel restriction
based on this new omicron variant we've
had our first case discovered and there
probably have been cases here in the u.s
but the first official one in california
what what do you think about this biden
policy
yeah you know we we have
started off with very simple approaches
like we don't know what we're dealing
with let's let's bend the curve for two
weeks do you remember that comment brett
that metastasized into this overreaching
authoritarianism so now we almost had a
reflexive response and start doing
things we would never think of allowing
even two years ago and omicron is a
virus that has 50 mutations in it 32 on
the spike protein i've done my homework
on it we just don't know we don't know
if it's more contagious we don't know if
it's more likely to make you sick we
don't even know if it makes you more
likely to get ill if you've been
vaccinated so in the face of a lot of
unknowing we don't just go snap
decisions about big-time changes that
will affect our economy affect our
people and and bring fear to a
population is just getting out of the
original covent pandemic i think we need
to go slowly with a calm hand like you
would in surgery don't rush the
decisions and one thing i think we've
seen a lot of is people who just don't
know the answers start barking out
authoritarian comments because it makes
them seem like they're in control but if
you don't have a good understanding
what's going down it just means you're
making mistakes you know you run your
show you run your operating room when
you if you win are in the senate you're
one out of a hundred you okay with that
i'm okay you know in the operating room
you're not by yourself on this on the
show as you know where you are right now
there's a dozen people staring at you i
build teams i make sure we respect each
other we work together and that's why we
win because we work it together all
right 2004 oprah winfrey brings you on
the show uh you become a success and a
friend of hers obviously throughout she
is known to be a democrat
is she going to endorse this run
i actually spoke to oprah recently she
told me to follow my heart she's been a
wonderful mentor to me the fairest woman
i've ever worked with um and a great and
a sage advisor of mine i actually don't
want her to get involved in any way at
first i don't want to hurt her and the
biggest advice i'm getting from my
friends is thank you for doing this
because you're going to get hurt and i
think that's true so i don't want people
having to take bullets when i should be
taking them myself but i'll be calling
her and asking advice and uh and
interested in her comments uh but i
think both with oprah and many other
people in my life that have been mentors
of mine i want them safe
dr oz we'll be following this race
thanks for coming on
god bless you brett take care hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else